Luxemburgo es el único país del mundo cuyo
Primer Ministro es abiertamente homosexual.
Hablamos de una de las sociedades más tolerantes
y abiertas del planeta. De hecho, con poco
más de 500.000 habitantes, el 40% son inmigrantes.
En otras palabras, que Luxemburgo es el país
más pequeño de la Unión Europea y, a la
vez, el que más población inmigrante tiene.
Sin embargo, lo que ha hecho famoso a Luxemburgo
se resume en una palabra: DINERO. Sí, amigos
de VisualPolitik, el Gran Ducado de Luxemburgo
está entre los 3 países más ricos del planeta.
Aquí, el salario mínimo roza los 2000 euros
al mes. Y eso es el salario mínimo, porque
lo normal es cobrar por encima de los 5000.
Para que os hagáis una idea, los luxemburgueses
tienen una renta per cápita 2 veces más
alta que la de los australianos o los daneses.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque este número
tiene truco! Veréis, casi la mitad de los
trabajadores de Luxemburgo no residen en este
país. Todos los días, alrededor de 160.000
personas cruzan las fronteras para trabajar
y después se vuelven a sus casas en Alemania,
Francia o Bélgica. Es decir, que generan
riqueza en el país pero no viven en el mismo.
Por eso, cuando dividimos el PIB de Luxemburgo
entre su población, nos sale una cifra tan
alta.
Pero, con o sin desviaciones estadísticas,
es innegable que Luxemburgo es algo así como
un país de millonarios. Y eso explica que
su capital, la Ciudad de Luxemburgo, sea también
una de las ciudades con mayor calidad de vida
del mundo.
Muchos pensaréis que todo esto se debe a
que Luxemburgo es un paraíso fiscal. Pero
lo cierto es que otros países como Malta
o Chipre también atraen a cientos de empresas
con impuestos bajos y no son, ni la mitad
de ricos que Luxemburgo.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Qué tiene Luxemburgo
para ser tan inmensamente rico? ¿Qué han
hecho en este país para disfrutar de semejante
estilo de vida? Y lo que es más importante
¿Hay algún elemento de la política luxemburguesa
que podríamos importar a nuestros países?
Hoy vamos a responder a esta pregunta… y
además, al final del vídeo va a haber una
sorpresa. Pero antes, vamos a ver un poco
de historia.
LOS REYES DEL ACERO
En el año 1815, El Gran Ducado de Luxemburgo
se convierte en un país “independiente”.
Y digo “independiente” entre comillas
porque ninguno de sus vecinos reconocieron
del todo esa independencia.
Francia y Prusia, que es lo que hoy en día
conocemos como Alemania, se pelearon por el
control de este ducado en varias ocasiones.
Es más, aunque su gobierno quisiera ser independiente,
el territorio de Luxemburgo era propiedad
del rey Guillermo 3º de Holanda.
Durante estos años, Luxemburgo estaba lejos
de ser un país rico. La mayor parte de sus
ciudadanos sobrevivían gracias a la agricultura
y la minería del hierro. Para que os hagáis
una idea, en estas décadas, el país perdía
población a marchas forzadas porque 1 de
cada 5 luxemburgueses emigraba a los Estados
Unidos.
Sin embargo, tener como vecinos a dos potencias
enfrentadas como eran Francia y Prusia también
tiene sus ventajas. Veréis, durante esta
época, Alemania no existía como país. En
su lugar, había varias repúblicas, reinos
y ducados, unidos bajo una confederación.
Si queréis entender lo que es una confederación,
podéis hacer click en este otro vídeo.
Lo cierto es que todos estos estados alemanes
también comerciaban entre ellos. Habían
creado una especia de área de libre comercio
a la que llamaban el ZOLLVEREIN.
Pues bien, en 1942, Luxemburgo entra a formar
parte de este ZOLLVEREIN. Desde entonces,
la historia no volvió a ser la misma.
Como os decía antes, la paupérrima economía
de Luxemburgo se basaba en dos sectores: agricultura
y minería del hierro. No olvidéis que estábamos
en plena Revolución Industrial, el acero
se utilizaba para prácticamente todo y a
los luxemburgueses les salía por las orejas.
¡Pero no sólo eso! Hablamos de un país
minúsculo, situado en el punto donde se junta
ALEMANIA, FRANCIA y BÉLGICA. En otras palabras,
que eran el enclave perfecto para construir
un ferrocarril para enviar mercancías a estos
tres países. De repente, Luxemburgo se había
convertido en el centro de todas las rutas
comerciales y uno de los mayores proveedores
de hierro y acero del mundo. De hecho, muchos
de esos rascacielos que vemos en Chicago y
Nueva York, se construyeron con vigas fabricadas
en este país. Y eso explica que las empresas
de acero más grandes del mundo sean luxemburguesas.
Entre otras, la más grande de todas, la que
hoy se conoce bajo el nombre de ARCELOR MITTAL
y que seguro que habéis visto más de una
vez en los periódicos de economía.
Dicho de otra forma, que en unas pocas décadas
Luxemburgo había pasado de ser un territorio
relativamente pobre a situarse al mismo nivel
que sus vecinos. Pero todavía faltaba algo
muy importante para que se convirtiera en
el gigante económico que es hoy en día…
Y ese “algo” es nada más y nada menos
que…
El año en el que Luxemburgo saca su ley de
Holdings empresariales. Y os preguntaréis
¿Qué es un holding empresarial? Pues bien,
vamos a tomar como ejemplo la COCA-COLA. Por
un lado, Coca-Cola es una marca de refrescos
pero, por el otro, tenemos a la COCA-COLA
COMPANY, que es una macro compañía que engloba
a muchas otras empresas como FANTA, SCHWEPPES
o la propia Coca-Cola. Pues bien, esta macro
compañía es un holding. Y las empresas que
lo integran se llaman FILIALES.
Las filiales pueden estar repartidas por distintos
países y son las encargadas de producir y
distribuir las bebidas. Sin embargo, la función
del HOLDING es, simplemente, administrar la
propiedad de estas FILIALES.
Pues bien, esta ley de 1929 tenía unas condiciones
fiscales fantásticas para los Holdings. Básicamente,
pagaban alrededor de un 1% de impuestos. Eran
los años 30, por aquel momento, la figura
del holding no estaba tan extendida como hoy
en día. Para que os hagáis una idea, por
aquella época, Coca-Cola estaba empezando
a expandirse a otros países. Pero todavía
no era el gigante que es ahora. En otras palabras,
que Luxemburgo crecía, sí, pero no mucho
más que otros países.
Sin embargo, en los años 70 es la época
donde las empresas de EEUU conquistan los
mercados europeos y asiáticos, que a su vez
tenían más dinero para consumir. En esta
época es cuando surgen muchos de esos conglomerados
empresariales que conocemos hoy en día. Es
decir, que, de repente, aparecieron montones
de HOLDINGS cuyos beneficios llegan de distintas
partes del mundo ¿Y dónde se situaban? Pues,
ya puestos a elegir, buscaban un lugar donde
pagar los menos impuestos posibles. Luxemburgo
ofrecía todo eso y mucho más. Para los años
60 y 70, el país ya contaba con una industria
financiera muy bien especializada. Los mejores
contables, abogados y economistas dispuestos
a ayudar a estos grande empresarios a sacarle
el máximo partido a las leyes luxemburguesas.
Y así es como este país entró en su década
de plata.
Tal cual como lo veis… la economía de Luxemburgo
se duplicó en menos de 6 años… Vamos,
que ríete tu de China o Singapur… Y habéis
oído bien, he dicho “década de plata”.
Porque todo este crecimiento fue una tontería
comparado con lo que vino después…
Pensadlo bien, hablamos ya de los años 2000;
el boom de las empresas de internet. Grandes
gigantes financieros que operan en todo el
mundo, tienen decenas de filiales repartidas
por todo el planeta y no están circunscritas
a ningún territorio concreto, porque hacen
ventas en todas partes. En otras palabras,
las empresas tecnológicas eran las más indicadas
para establecerse en Luxemburgo. Así que…
si creíais que un país que ya era multimillonario
no podía crecer más… echad un vistazo
a esta gráfica
Por favor, si algún día la palabra “NACHOVIDALIANO”
aparece en el diccionario de la R.A.E., quiero
que utilicen esta gráfica como ilustración.
No sé si os habéis fijado, pero en sólo
5 años, Luxemburgo pasó de tener una renta
per cápita de 50.000 dólares, que ya es
bastante, a superar los 100.000 dólares.
Cuando vives en un país con una renta per
cápita de 100.000 dólares, haces el kalimotxo
con Vega Sicilia. Para que os hagáis una
idea, el Audi A3 es el tercer coche más vendido
en Luxemburgo.
¡Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando! Que este
país se ha hecho rico gracias a la evasión
de impuestos ¿Verdad? Pues la respuesta es
mucho más compleja que todo esto. Veréis,
el hecho de que un HOLDING corporativo esté
ubicado en Luxemburgo no significa que sus
filiales no tengan que pagar impuestos en
otros países. Al menos en teoría. Por ejemplo,
el holding de AMAZON tiene su sede en Luxemburgo.
Sin embargo, su filial española, es decir,
la empresa que se encarga de vender los productos
y gestionar los envíos en este país, tiene
que tributar en España. Bueno, al menos en
teoría. En la práctica, es muy distinto…
LUXLEAKS
Volvamos al ejemplo de Amazon. Como decíamos,
los beneficios que gane su filial española
tienen que tributar en España ¿Verdad? Pero…
¿Y si no tuvieran beneficios? Imaginad que,
justo antes de ir a pagar los impuestos, Amazon
España pide un préstamo enorme. Un préstamo
con un tipo de interés altísimo. Tanto,
que deja temblando su cuenta de resultados.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Quién les presta ese
dinero? ¡Efectivamente! El holding que tiene
Amazon en Luxemburgo. De esta forma, las filiales
de esta empresa apenas tienen declaran beneficios.
De una forma u otra, casi todo ese dinero
termina en la cuenta luxemburguesa, que como
hemos dicho antes, paga unos impuestos mucho
más bajos.
Por supuesto que todo esto es legal. Pero
en 2009, en mitad de la gran crisis financiera,
el Gobierno de EEUU se dio cuenta de la cantidad
de dinero que estaba perdiendo con todas esas
grandes empresas.
“Por eso hoy voy a anunciar un paquete de
propuestas para luchar contra la evasión
ilegal de impuestos fuera del país, cerrar
los vacíos legales y hacer más rentable
que las empresas creen trabajos aquí, en
Estados Unidos.”
A partir de aquí, el resto de gobiernos siguieron
el ejemplo de Obama. No olvidéis que Luxemburgo
es uno de los miembros fundadores de la Unión
Europea. Eso significa que sus compañeros
de club podían hacer aún más presión política.
Pero, sin duda alguna, la verdadera crisis
en este país llegó en el año 2014. En este
momento es cuando un grupo de contables publicaron
miles de datos privados de todas estas grandes
compañías. Gracias al llamado LUXLEAKS,
todos hemos podido ver las estrategias de
evasión fiscal que habían puesto en práctica
miles de corporaciones.
¿Recordáis lo que os he contado de los préstamos
entre distintas filiales de un mismo holding?
Pues todavía podemos mejorar aún más este
esquema.
Veréis, todas estas grandes empresas contratan
a grandes consultoras para que les lleven
la contabilidad. Consultoras como, por ejemplo,
PRICE WATERHOUSE COOPERS que tienen una enorme
cartera de clientes en Luxemburgo. Tantos
clientes como para poder sentarse a negociar,
directamente, con el Primer Ministro del país
que por entonces era Jean-Claude Juncker.
Juncker en el punto de mira tras las revelaciones
de evasión fiscal en Luxemburgo.
Los documentos filtrados demostrarían acuerdos
fiscales negociados por PricewaterhouseCoopers.
Como os podéis imaginar, la publicación
de estos LuxLeaks ha cambiado totalmente las
reglas de juego. De hecho, en 2017 Luxemburgo
ya ha sacado una nueva reforma fiscal. Y,
probablemente, muchos de estos acuerdos preferenciales
con grandes compañías pasen a ser historia.
¡Pero esperad un momento! Porque esto no
significa el fin de la prosperidad luxemburguesa.
Más bien todo lo contrario.
Es más, pese a todas estas turbulencias políticas,
este país creció el año pasado a un ritmo
del 4,2%. Mucho más rápido que España o
que, prácticamente, cualquier otro país
Europeo.
Teniendo tantísimo dinero ahorrado, los Luxemburgueses
han podido invertir en muchos otros sectores.
Por supuesto que tenemos el acero, los bancos
y… el espacio.
“La apuesta de Luxemburgo por la industria
especial muestra señales de éxito temprano”
Tal cual como lo oís. De hecho, Luxemburgo
y Estados Unidos han sido los dos primeros
países en sacar leyes para regular la minería
en el espacio exterior. Y en esta pequeña
nación esperan convertirse en el Silicon
Valley del espacio.
¡Y eso también explica, en parte, esta nueva
reforma fiscal que han sacado en este año
2017! Por supuesto, el Gobierno de Luxemburgo
ya no quiere ayudar a las grandes corporaciones
a evadir impuestos. Al menos, eso es lo que
dicen oficialmente. En su lugar, han reducido
los impuestos para las empresas pequeñas.
Es decir, que quieren mejorar las condiciones
para que puedan surgir nuevas startups tecnológicas...
pero de eso hablaremos en un próximo vídeo.
Así que ahora la pregunta es ¿Volveremos
a ver un crecimiento vertiginoso en la economía
de Luxemburgo? ¿Veremos algún día cómo
este país se convierte en el líder mundial
de la industria aeroespacial? Podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
¡Y ahora llega la sorpresa! ¿Os acordáis
de nuestros amigos de CHINA UNCENSORED? Pues
nos han escrito para pedirnos que hagamos
un CHALLENGE de esos que se hacen en youtube.
Como sabéis, al gobierno Chino no le gusta
la disidencia política. Y tienen una especial
fijación con los practicantes del FALUN GONG,
que es un tipo de meditación trascendental.
Cada año, miles de personas son capturadas
o asesinadas por esta razón. Especialmente
las mujeres.
Y para que todos estemos concienciados con
este causa, ANASTASIA LIN, que es una activista
y modelo, ha sacado este reto, el #LOTUSCHALLENGE.
La idea es que ahora tengo que grabarme haciendo
YOGA durante 5 segundos. Y son 5 segundos
porque si fueran 5 minutos, tendría que llamar
a una ambulancia. Así que allá voy.
Mientras tanto, en este otro vídeo os contamos
la historia de QATAR, otro de los países
más ricos del mundo. Haced click aquí para
verlo.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
al canal para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado este vídeo,
dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el próximo. Un
abrazo y hasta pronto!